nocentini town hall in thaksin he is not here i
was here this epic disc to my
wigs thor 6 by
public affairs aviation and to the
democratic goods of the created all of ikea
once the amateur fra 84 14 tanks dated
is especially qanooni gimont and which
closes ineffective at 6 tons and the fair
use in algeria of hollowy there is a
prototype adapter at dr raphaël
glucksmann mr president dear
colleagues since i have been a deputy
we have voted resolutions on
very diverse subjects  on countries as
far away as indonesia but we
haven't had a word not a word about the
tremendous revolution taking place
just across the mediterranean in
algeria not a word of support for these
millions of algerian women  and Algerians
who have been marching in the streets of Algiers
other Algerian cities for nine
months for democracy justice
dignity
not a word about the arrests the
pressures the violence that
befalls them not a word about the cases
torture now proven this
complicit silence skillfully maintained by
powerful lobbies can no longer last
the resolution of solidarity that we are
going to vote today is not an
interference it is the end of an immense
injustice
it is time dear colleagues of  show
that we are at the side of the
Algerian people so as we say at home
one two three viva l'algérie
it would be done in history and by household
after all if an actor he is not used
bergin at the time
president catherine  and criminal mind in
ramadani facing no sex our sheets young
and after described the cloud one is in
oneself a tribal leader or discriminated
rothschild bank brothers story
that fans of alain east then south to
knysna time and charter in
seconds  before i want a
bullying offer some sort of an obsession
tauben fliegen tizi ouzou jean
revol hatcher us win a rare tina
opens tomorrow would be this by a fashion
alain vinard raich a brief to make
eu active  rope she offered
blacksmiths rosing and young girls
lie to monsters relate to
sellers and buyers are bums
like someone talking again bidding
of us and our ears wedding
none or funny named jean yves top
march 10 voltaire direct d  other other
hot and that this film lead us to
reject and strongly her body of anita hero
fears at the bug first next march at the
forum frolov new world truck my job
would suit us and your priests friends
would have so that's it  fees remaining
donovan at the time livestock lpc
state aids mr president let's imagine hope let's
dream for a moment
let's imagine that this immense movement which
has been raising today's algeria for so many months
determined young people aspiring
to dignity the state of  right
and equity let's imagine that this
movement prevails it would then not
only be the happiness and the pride
of algeria
it would be the mobilization of all these
energies in favor of the resumption of the international
dialogue  he Maghrebian st of
economic and cultural cooperation
with europe and aid from both
shores of the mediterranean to
sub-
saharan africa would be the realization of our
common aspirations for all of us
maghrebians and europeans
and that is why we  we must
adopt this resolution against an
intolerable and absurd repression which
risks shattering this beautiful dream algeria
let's say to algeria in struggle hope the
support and affection of europe that
's freestyle guetta and akon flabbergasted
roster grosse  tomato and mathieu costa
has neither october management which will
allow ricky romero suffered from his family and
all that liberals with the summary fifa star
and gloféi setbacks of organs to
build has now with two
handcuffed vans this time mister you follow me
home the anah social micro atx group
clearly according to this newspaper or miss the miss
castle masmoudi ginter scullino the folk
would have told me that there is the fofolle they
are in crisis was given at launch
of mill  ions of users it alternates
periods so much in town suffice at
campaign in crisis mode has woman
still casting stay at horton
krishnasamy foundation cheriet screen
log 10 most this press for half
rillettes stir up a moment of
political roots victory at the masters guinot
mary cohr
une  shop window in mons remain in russian
rates hadj territory denis are andré
religion document d'offre very proud of the
little ones at the end of respite from free speech
threw to view it homeland
now the famine is going strong
europe line and françois-xavier pélamis in
europe and a folk  little late morning in
europe and a crazy series of tricks to
lift in europa from europeans chemistry at
teddy universal and baptiste ok but you
love my nantes fans nomination was
unalterable
he risks the open tahar is rich from 25
expensive cities that this loan is president
for more than nine months,
Algerian and Algerian citizens have been
admired by the world for
their democratic demands
expressed in a peaceful but
above all determined manner, algeria is
committed, as we know, to respecting
fundamental human rights by being a
signatory to several international treaties,
including the
universal declaration of human rights and the
international covenant on
civil and political rights  to cite only
those,
respect for freedom of expression
and demonstration are therefore guaranteed by
the Algerian constitution
and yet dozens of
personalities are currently in
detention for having simply
expressed an option on the pretext
that it would undermine the
national media unit were put under
pressure and had to cease their
activities as well as ngos through
our resolution the european parliament
urge the algerian authorities to
release all political prisoners
and prisoners of conscience
human rights and fundamental freedoms
that Algeria has undertaken to respect
must be guaranteed  antis in particular the
freedoms of expression and
demonstration Europe and friend of Algeria but
above all friend of all Algerians and
Algerian women
it is our duty to recall the
common priorities of partnership
adopted in March 2010 is in which
the  both parties reaffirmed their
commitment to respect the
universal values of democracy the rule of la
and human rights thank
you it would be done stay in line or in pr
ctice if we have goals
of free and fair golf world as we kn
w my  maghreb sad party and
laughs that his brothers historian at the
marathon of root in the water here is 10
km or ja
thank you sir president dear
colleagues the group of greens ale
refused to support the inclusion of an
emergency resolution on the  algeria on
the agenda of the plenary session
for the following reasons the care of
the political agenda which falls just
before the elections of December 12 the
risk of politicizing human rights  ins
the risk of degrading the legitimacy or
the credibility of the opposition and of the
Algerians who have been showing for nine
months the risk of fueling the rhetoric
of the regimes in power on alleged
foreign interference
the conviction that Algeria you deserve
much more than  a resolution which, although
containing strong and important messages
of support for Algerians,
has shortcomings and
irrelevant references, despite these
expressed reservations, we will vote in
favor of this resolution,
however our support for the Algerian people will
not stop there.
like what we have done since March
2019 we remain mobilized alongside the
Algerian people in their
legitimate claim for their freedom and their rights
we salute the exemplary nature of the
Algerian people in their way of expressing their
desire for change in an
extremely  peaceful
in fine and we hope that it will be
the Algerian people who alone decide
their future
and as we d  it at home and in the
language of to Algerians
tahya el djazaïr long live algeria
thank you brothers story and we hesitate
and girls and blaquart simple people also
pessimistic sister suzanne bus as
insists guy kloten milton and
nomadic symbolic marches studio arc and tokyo
zen came from no wheat card is what
there is to do from nairobi girl who does not
fear them there are neighborhoods and
linate in tripoli this image is for
but the end of hadopi was authoritative
in fundamentals because we
procure  but steen o'mara taffetas que
democratiya au kilo scolari by adapting
I have president what is happening in
algeria can not leave anyone
indifferent
for two reasons the first it is based
on the principle the second it is based on the
reality
the principles is that  wherever
freedoms are flouted
we must act to defend the
principles
the reality is tears
from the suffocation of the blood of distress
and also the fact that between algeria and
France
there is a historical, economic,
political and emotional link
if the people over there have no problem, they
leave Algeria and it happens in
difficult conditions in France that she
can no longer can no longer, it's not that
she doesn't want to  more can no longer
welcome
I believe that we must approve this
resolution
in the name of freedoms in the name of our
principles and perhaps also in the names of
what makes us exist it would be done
rest in gatineau ethics marathon
and matt  smith tons in the ear to the
resolution
the coach of nistos the manila offers
30 with our lot 1 90 m
no problem in france in russia
our contact group will have a suture
in the forehead he enters as 06 m gold
priority ground ukrainian d  'a notch
it would be restored in the
literary west sean ryan alpin say colic
cei will revolt jones day by day
recognize each other internation ale sdk
territory and cordoba 2 see all your
tourists algeria is one 30 and 50 places
offensive quentris  demos persecutes
christian siriano ministry of the ankh
lost fifteen protestants churchill
and colors of rigaud worship in
vinassan title 6-2 3-2 tab came out of the
ring matrix
yes requests do to the txistu be right
fourie reopen you ask him founded
minister of  interior everything is proof
organization in ce1 corric de youtou
Algerian press officials to comply
with guarantee to the freedom of religion
established in de hajja constitution
thank you forget about your photos your of
his door and cross gates by
phone
it is however that he  would remain
mr president madam high
representative the algerian regime with
bonuses freedom they have been oppressing
freedoms since february 22 the day of the
launch
iraq the popular movement of
peaceful protest
séné in the streets of algiers has
now spread to the whole country  in the sights
of the demonstrators today the
presidential elections of December 12
set by the army and which announces a pe  u
even more the freezing of power the
Algerian regime flouts the rights of
students journalists
trade unionists workers who have been in
the streets for 10 months now and this
in particular the 42 demonstrators
sentenced to six months in prison
for marching with the flag  Amazigh
because flying a Berber flag
in the streets of Algiers
today leads to prison our
resolution precisely condemns all these
authoritarian excesses of the regime it says
our attachment to the thirst
for independence of the Algerian people of the
youth who suffer from illness  life and
as they say over there also talent bin
al hurria yes we ask
for freedom for the algerian people brother the story
there is a
previous graff adapter and alto representative
and mir america find that these scrolls
or bad dreams of christ title
to solutions is the dictatorship
religious freedom as if religion
is broke a taboo why motivates them
we do not know  s by their father your hand and
help religious persecution a
particular cost and the
aftermath stéphane ricordeau that algeria to her
comes from douaisis my country in the world
whose opening of the fictional
cellectis holds
bricorama au primate can is alone in the
dobrée museum he governs our céline
to the gains to others that they have a
bigger cruiser is not easy to
remain talented too much he makes
beds protesting in cash on the
victims and the persecution and smiles
christiane convert to islam
pernod  and religious freedom has and
indirect to the fundamental and inalienable
of the human person
yet few of certain goods of the six
cities where during each team is idiot
spiritaines is confronted with
religion is a particle is ridiculous
to christiane represses 2008 the parents
say it papa benedict  as quickly chose my
camp bitche caviar ischios being
tengrela the città interlude check
around the art and the greens its chu  you
that of the reread john bercow stay
motivated because sticking there airs extreme
skill important and not google earth
and the words and libertarian lidge
nasserdine other championships volta
to be adouna terminology a
politically correct thanks to his brothers
and sisters
this n'  is not the solution is political
the repression of the demonstration does
not worry about attacking us his freedom
a knife the employees christian
institute at the weddings and atel bourrinism
characteristic of the decision-makers and
less young and loïck peyron
he supposes that indeed others like we
libya  to the chileans who sound dumb to
lose only when there were
initially launched in jest at the luff and
the masses of the national strauss nuts and
headquarters respect each other of friends but
not specially procure t4 and yahoo de los
peces temenos collaborate for the  stage
well bros she the devolution of their
daughter migrant feel and where the army of
rural elders païni special maintain
spain of one of the  machine inputs
final climb media and murcia or
the display and brooms with the
ability that right now from the wrapped
with cyril to the austere ostal makes this
conflict between mattila he repaired
ascione by anita from the prime effect to  the
breakage or and the maintenance of the
migration policy and dacia would be restored
see if a year ago the decline in the
rivers
thank you Mr. President for 130
years from 1830 to 1962 Algeria will have been a
country where religious freedom reigned
for 130  years Christian Jews and
Muslims could practice their
respective religions in complete
serenity outside of any extremist reading,
starting with that of Islam for
nearly 60 years the Algerian power from
the fln has continued to undermine the
free religious practice of
Jewish and Christian minorities until their virtual
disappearance from the country
today holding a bible in your
bag can cost up to 5 years in prison
these incessant attacks on the so  Also
against memory, successive governments
have deliberately allowed
violent vandalism to be exercised against
Jewish and Christian cemeteries. It
is because it has lost this
pluralism that Algeria for 30 years has been
tossed between a
totalitarian  jihadist terrorism
without repentance or false modesty we
must condemn and face up to its
responsibilities
an intolerant and worn-out power would be
alliston to get some of catalonia brings back
to our militants to find cedrika
its assets cat's eyes heroes of rice and
tahiti morning and then to bienne but  by
fashionable politics at the chrono takan that
you brought by your ear what they
could at the same
time suddenly
and with brocade had obtained seven
feet candles if you you never know this
leaflet nor fashion this poc kill her
chuck norris caravan messenger  sco for
a listening or nicole machine released movie
nimani amiens the rubble of the toxi not
the hot lines which hits the board of
casino ni pon  t ni jovani national china
tahkout saudi and insured by our
customs china minsheng management what
was possible for me
do not sign anytime soon
everything is not for mina who the day before
yesterday abbot marc ravalomanana from cauvery
potro to beta bull zueva  how this
quick goal minyana coaching deco
it would be done restore time when I
pass it aguilar yann allot previous
visit to bologhine and clark and
elaboration and this by will he
know nothing of debating foreign policy
which could certainly
European diplomacy by  the first
democracy and resources to izon
davideau repression tense and in
extension is necessary their anger
that you have nothing fo-
territorial application of the european treaty between
1957 and 1962 independent carole
advocates freedom from the repressive regime of
character  non-commissioned member of the
second skin that this teacher at the
multi mom you're stupid detention of
servants pressure after 9 p.m. and
mass arrest  ive dissidents are considered
by action for an open internet and its
ticket faces selector
and president bouteflika positrons
moth to filter lucio for
re-election approached the present for the
presidency
the supports the president such scenario
that as many we selected  by
four blows instead of
caspar doublets she in September is finally
separated the back and clean musicians who
have maintained the renters
it is a turnbuckle represses
systematically prohibited if old
where lyon and european are there risks
of this audacity or diplomacy  full-
fledged presstalis is normal inad of
fundamental things and spar
acquired democracy and freedom it is
finally a possible scenario the
ccir president christophe morel time
the president so my group is not a
signatory of this resolution but as
far as I am concerned  regards me in support and
the spirit and the letter
we obviously did not expect
today to  to be alongside the
Algerian democrats who fight
tirelessly against corruption for
fundamental freedoms for
social justice
and yes indeed today as
we speak there is repression
there are journalists who are acquired
and have demonstrators who are
unfairly given a take there is an
opposition that is being bullied and inevitably
we cannot be silent
so I too, like some colleagues,
I regret that this resolution
comes now rather than in
February when there was a
powerful citizens' movement which is in the process of  stand
up and that we would have needed our
support and I know very well that while
we are in an electoral process
which is as questionable as challenging
the power will obviously instrumentalize
our work to talk about interference and
send the demonstrators back
to  hypothetical foreign agents
but the truth all the same is that there is
this political situation and it is
not interference  ence it is rather our
unwavering support for the Algerian people
and in particular for a youth who are
eager for dignity who are hungry for freedom
who are hungry for justice and it is of them that
we are thinking today when
we take these words her brothers  and
sisters in the aurès there is time
this one is that it is often how they
count each for themselves and taurou
police who work on boya democracy
awarded to the maximum proto in bordeaux it is
indeed m brigitte in French in the
text  had saved political lives to the
maximum arab spring and as a suspect
victor b in melbourne and kaduna tauriac
it's having problems and it's quite
soft these impostors compel me to
bruges streaming
even if it also lied to us because I
move better act to shirk and
pitcher negative neither you nor without other
inrix face of households
amadou and his colleagues argued that
this card which
marvin marvin from north african in guinea marveled me because
he would not see it as a victory  carl medjani
great their income young people on the left
there will be a sharing a tent as sahara
is from a dead fim group maurice
christie in the region
she will be put back in christ
and internationally in 2001 he is
only  a governor diagonal niche
taunt with m
the smirt in vonnas will have delighted shankar
colors and a rouste dead
karadiyanaru jim nill young arkoon
close with arms and their good situation
does he come norilsk dined on
agreements week according to a grid
of honor at  the crook made to keep
his shots like a group like that would have
stayed in the vehicle rolls on alpine skis
as usual civic ac omonia
festicadie who athena liberia in naftal makes you
not condone that cannabis is your
analysis you in naples au  noses after 6.4
said that cake boxes in our
museums know very well how to subject them to
ski prius 110 km 1 nasri 6 cryptography
gones they would perceive this crisis
believes that hydro quebec romana is
convenient to tra  to chandeliers race is
stable or to comac laughed a lot
behind the commissions body to a body
festicadie who lose excuses mandate
room even admits m
also robbie keane also at fault
also venal Kosovar guerrilla stealing his
remaining costs at the lille osc look
delegation of castillet exxon  is
propitious thank you Mr.
President Algeria is not only a neighboring country
it is of course but Algeria and
above all a partner to
a political partner an economic partner
a friend country for many
European citizens algeria also the family therefore  we
share a country with others we start
from a country that is very close to us a
country that is friendly to the Algerian people
I think the first feeling that
all of us in europe
feeling friendship and closeness
our respect for the  sovereignty
and autonomy of Algeria is total
I think it is very important that
these debates reaffirm its in the
strongest the clearest way it is to the
Algerians and had only to decide
the present and the future of their country and
it is for this reason exactly for
this reason that the Algerians must
be free to express themselves with the
guarantees that their constitution and the
international agreements that have been
signed  by
algeria guarantees it rare on a supposed
date algeria is serious all that
raping me doing all the rest info masters
indian constitution part at the top of a
gray nation tea months and with the
association of women d'ayodhya as we day
european springboks route to
fundamentals freedom in claudine
policy of freedom freedom of
expression of right to peer or assembly
does harm free dom press
guarantee of a decoration version human
rights watch
queenstown having associated with climatic
on the shoulders of a strange
indycar acting challenge right now in algeria
can enjoy this rights the review this
date according to women will be sisters
to beasts or day racing when  s of these
examinations seduce consist between
guests to our algeria by our
interlocutors it is too much the screw
built in greening and i believe
that we continue to be of match date
like that of a camp but where it
continues to pass not have everything and
pull the rating us energy agency kabyle
concern exports continue
from russian to dresden hans von neipperg
france to namsos date
the freestore he is a little too close
she recalls